platas de aceite vegetal unos pocos
kilos de arroz frijoles y granos para
más de 10 millones de yemeníes esta
simple lista de compras es una ayuda
crítica que reciben del programa mundial
de alimentos hacemos un llamado a todas
las organizaciones para que distribuyan
mensualmente como antes ahora mismo no
hemos recibido nada en los últimos meses
ni comida ni otra cosa esto no es
suficiente para nosotros ni para
nuestros hijos la amenaza de la hambruna
es sólo uno de los efectos secundarios
de una década de caos a inicios de 2011
la primavera árabe se apoderó del país
gracias en gran parte a una situación
económica que ya era terrible miles de
personas se tomaron las calles de la
capital saná para pedir la renuncia del
presidente de larga data
ali abdullah saleh mientras que sus
leales organizaron sus contra protestas
pero el punto de quiebre llegó en marzo
cuando las fuerzas de saleh abrieron
fuego contra los manifestantes y mataron
a 52 personas
la situación económica en pero en 2014
con la caída mundial de los precios del
petróleo ese mismo año un conflicto
político está hecho entre el gobierno y
los rebeldes hutíes respaldados por irán
una lucha de poder de seis años que
redefiniría el panorama del país el cual
perdura hasta hoy los enfrentamientos
sin citar en la intervención de una
coalición militar liderada por arabia
saudita en respaldo al gobierno yemení
pero los ciudadanos del país se fueron
los que más sufrieron la caída según
naciones unidas
se me está experimentando la peor crisis
humanitaria del mundo el cob y el cólera
y la difteria han desgarrado al país más
de 3 millones de personas han sido
desplazadas y cerca del 80% de la
población necesita algún tipo de ayuda
para sobrevivir los paquetes de comida
se han reducido en un 50% y eso ha
deteriorado la situación de las personas
la malversación y la corrupción
continúan alimentando la economía de
guerra la onu estima aproximadamente 2
mil millones de dólares perdidos en
fondos de ayuda para yemen